Aswin Punathembekar: And we
thought we would kick it off
with a few questions for Lana
about tracing the trajectory of
the book, where it comes from
and how her thinking has
evolved. That's all right.
Should we get started?
Lana Swartz: Sure. Yeah. I mean,
the other thing, just by way of
introduction, I wanted to say
was, you know, when asked when,
and I talked about this, we were
initially imagining it, just
the, as we understood it as kind
of a closed group conversation
with CMS students, which I'm
totally excited for it to, for
all kinds of people, some of
whom I know, some of them, I
don't to be here. But we do.
Because we, you know, we're both
alumni of CMS, we do want to
make sure that are kind of
initial and primary audience are
the graduate students. So we're
going to kind of have that lens
in mind. And we want to also be
sure to answer questions and
talk both about the book, but
also about the trajectories of
both of our careers, as to CMS
folks from two different eras,
really, and different arrows
from the present, who have made
academic careers and are now in
the same department somewhat,
you know, quite fortuitously. So
yeah, so in addition to the
book, I do want this to take
this opportunity to have a kind
of broader conversation. One of
the reasons why I asked, you
know, asked him to be my
interlocutor on this is that,
you know, we are colleagues now
and I'm really respect his work,
and I think he will, will, will
bring kind of an interesting,
others flip sides of the
conversation. But also, you
know, when I was a CMS student,
we got the word that that aswin
had just gotten a tenure track
job. And he was the first CMS
alum, as far as I knew, to get
the tenure track job. And as
part of our process and
selecting, you know, working up
to the thesis, you know, we were
asked to read papers, read prior
theses from previous CMS
students and, and I, one of the
ones that I read was aswin. So I
was always, I've been a big fan
of aswin. Since before he had a
tenure track job. And since I
was a CMS student, so I hope we
can do some meta stuff here, but
not too much. I guess. I think
Aswin Punathembekar: there'll be
a lot of fun. I already
instructed Andrew to delete
every possible copy there is of
my master's thesis.
No, it's so good.
Yeah, let's get going. So I
guess one of the two ways in
which CMS really shaped my
thinking, and I'm sure the same
for you, Lana is a to think
comparatively, which meant quite
simply to think across media
forms, to think across
historical moments and to think
across cultural contexts. And
the other key sort of phrase
that has stayed with me is to
think about media always, as in
transition. do with those two
things in mind, I thought we
could open the conversation by
having you reflect a little bit
on the conjuncture in terms of
when you began thinking about
this topic itself, as a project
you wanted to pursue, and sort
of have a temporal bracket of
sorts. So it was around 2007, or
eight, when you started actively
imagining this as a dissertation
project, and eventually a book
coming out of the financial
crisis that we were plunged into
at that moment in the US. And
now here we are in 2020, at a
very different political
conjuncture, but which has also
some serious financial and
political ramifications as well.
So with these two bookends in
mind, could you just start off
by telling us a little bit about
how that moment led to your even
beginning to imagine this as a
viable long term project?
Lana Swartz: Yeah, I absolutely
agree. And have found that the
term media in transition, which
I when I was in CMS, I was sort
of like a medium transition.
It's the name of the books that
you know, Thorburn and Henry
wrote and that's they have our
conference, blah, blah, blah,
what does even mean? But then
again, and again, it's something
I come back to and and this kind
of analytical tool that says,
Okay, let's look at moments of
media change. We're not
interested so much in New Media
for the sake of newness. We're
in Interested in moments of, you
know, disjuncture, and and
shifting and if we really zero
in and focus in on those moments
of change, you know, what do we
learn. And that really is the
primary analytic for my entire
book. Like every there is one
kind of big historical chapter
that looks at moments of media
change and looks at money as a
payment, or rather looks at
money as media, and then kind of
touches down at key moments of
change. But then every other
chapter that follows examines
the moment of newness, but also
all of the things that kind of
lead up to that moment of
newness. So absolutely, I think
and I think we'll likely kind of
circle back to that as we chat.
But to answer your question, and
I think this kind of is
interesting to think about the
kind of historiography of
transition. So you, you
mentioned that I started
conceiving of this as a
dissertation project around
2007 2008. And that's actually
not true. I, I started
conceiving as it as a
dissertation project, probably
closer to 2011 2012. So you
know, I finished CMS in 2009, I
had written a thesis on
counterfeit luxury goods, and
kind of regimes of ownership and
authorship. And then, I started
my PhD, the following year,
2009 2010, probably wasn't in
the thick of it, and until
thinking about dissertations for
another couple of years, but
it's it, absolutely. The moment
that the dissertation is born
out of is the 2008 2000, or
2007 2008, financial crisis, and
a variety of other media changes
that happened at that moment.
And it really is only
retrospectively. And this is why
I speak of, you know,
historiography that 2008 becomes
2008. So 2008, probably wasn't
2008 until 2010. Although maybe
2020 might already be 2020. So
thinking about like, when we
become aware of moments as being
moments, all that being said, I
started thinking the year
2007 2008 marks an important
moment for thinking about money
as a communication technology
because of a few, you know,
interrelated
factors. So we did, as you
mentioned, had the 2008 global
financial crisis, which I really
believe ignited a moment of kind
of rethinking money. So
suddenly, we had broad based
global movements that sort of
said, you know, what are the,
you know, like, why should
traditional governments and
traditional financial systems be
the primary producers of money?
Are there other ways to do the
economy? And of course, you
know, thinking about occupy and
those sort of things that wasn't
really till 2012 2013. So, like,
the way history moves is
interesting. And so yeah, so we
have this moment where we were
kind of collectively rethinking
the economy. I always go back to
this one onion article, which,
you know, sometimes it proves to
be true, that onion kind of like
speaks the truth. But that says,
you know, it was a headline that
said, the US economy or global
economy grinds to a halt, as
everyone realizes that money is
nothing more than a shared
delusion. And they this article
describes this like sudden
awakening, just like rippling
across the populace, where
suddenly a bank robber is like,
why am I robbing the bank? This
is so dumb, and someone about to
have their house foreclosed upon
is like, Oh, I don't, I don't
have to leave my house. That's
awesome. But then, and then
they're like, well, cool. Now
that we know this, what are we
going to do? And there's just a
moment of like, oh, wait a
minute, money actually serves
like a pretty useful purpose for
deciding how to broker goods and
services and how to figure out
how to communicate in an
economy. And so I kind of think
there's this like moment of
awakening, but then this moment
of, of like, okay, when the
rubber hits the road, how are we
actually going to think about
building new systems that might
be alternatives to the thing
that we've suddenly realized
maybe we don't want so that's,
that's there's that that that
factor and then also 2007 2008
was the emergence of the iPhone
followed quickly thereafter by
Android. So, so suddenly, we
were carrying around in our
pocket, you know, these what had
previously been like fairly
sophisticated computers that do
a lot of the things that we need
to kind of do money with. So
have some kind of universal
address book, hat like such as
Facebook, which that year is
also the one Facebook kind of
has the tipping point of
becoming this like truly kind of
mass scale
system
and keep a count of records. So
you know, various, you know, if
you have an Excel spreadsheet
and you have a way of
transmitting information And you
have a way of contacting someone
you kind of can like do money.
And that's, that's pretty much
all you need, in many ways and
hold. And then the hard part is
a system for authorizing and
making that the information kind
of socially guaranteed to be
valuable. And then of course, we
have m paisa, which was the, you
know, the first large scale
mobile money system. So there
had been attempts to do mobile
money and mobile payments for
the long time. And mostly in
Kenya, but also in other parts
of sub Saharan Africa, we had
the video proof of concept. So
suddenly, and so I traced that
as a moment where a lot of the
innovations that kind of became
FinTech became crypto became all
the things I kind of study in my
book. Were kind of born. So by
the time I finished the
dissertation, which was in 2000,
I don't know 14, did I finish?
Yeah, no 2015. You know, I had
been able to kind of follow
along with the cohort of people
who were trying to rethink money
from a bunch of different
angles, who all got interested
in it around the same time I
did. So as a fortuitous time to
study transition as it happened.
Aswin Punathembekar: Yeah, I
mean, that's a great start. And
I think what you've captured is
the difficulties involved in
mapping a moment as it unfolds.
But then when you finally get to
the end of a dissertation, and
you turn it into a book, you
have that space to then step
back and carefully historicize
it and then up to that moment,
but you do beautifully in the
book. And I'm just going to read
out a couple of sentences as a
way to get deeper into it. So at
the very beginning, what I
really like is the way you set
things up, offer a very clear
argument beginning. And then you
offer this wonderful structure
for the whole book. He said,
this is a book about the
cultural politics of
transactional technologies. It
offers a new way to think about
money as a communication medium
dependent on particular
technologies. And then you go on
to say that each chapter takes
up an essential mechanism of
payment, and explain how it
explains how it works, which you
do beautifully, how it got to be
that way, how it's changing, and
what implications those changes
may have. Until, right. And I
read this, and I thought,
especially in what you just
explained, it could not have
been obvious as a PhD student in
the Media and Communication
Department, that you could very
quickly and easily situate the
question of money and payment
within Media and Communication
Studies. It's not obvious at all
to begin with, right? And you
turn to James Kerry and some
other domains of media theory as
a way to then think through a
structure give it a theoretical
scaffolding. So could you then
take us to that next step? Which
is, once you propose the
dissertation, did your advisor
say that's crazy? And then be
how did you sort of how did you
work your way through different
disciplines to then come up with
this framework, and ground
yourself in media Communication
Studies, instead of going off
into cultural anthropology or
sociology or so on? Mm hmm.
Lana Swartz: Yeah. So I, um, so
as I mentioned, I was coming off
of a CMS thesis where I was
studying counterfeit luxury
goods, so like fake bags, fake
Louis Vuitton bags, and shoes,
and that sort of thing. And I
was studying the fan communities
who come together, who are
really kind of connoisseurs of
the fake, mostly entirely
online. And they, you know,
they're These are people who use
global you know, really kind of
interestingly, like global
supply chains. Today, they're
using things like WeChat and
Taobao to like order direct
from, you know, folks in China
who are making like, the best
fakes. And in many ways, these
fakes are like, better than the
real. And they say things like,
because they have like better
stitching, they're actually
handmade, whereas the real, the
reels are no longer actually
handmade. And they say things
like, you know, anyone can walk
into any, anyone with $2,000 can
walk into a Louis Vuitton store
and buy the real version. Only I
because I have the social
network, the technical savvy,
and the depth of expertise, to
understand what makes a perfect
fake, can buy the perfect fake
and I'm part of this community,
etc. And so I was really
interested at that moment in
studying kind of marketplaces,
as a culture and kind of the and
and the online communities that
are that come up around markets,
and also the, the Oh, and I'm
quite familiar with the Reddit
group that just got posted.
There's a few of those. So I
need to do, I would love to do
an update to that project sooner
rather than later. But we'll
see. And also kind of the
technologies that people use to
kind of do markets so I was
really attuned both through CMS
but also through an interest in
kind of sts science and
technology studies and
infrastructure studies. To look
not just at the way ideas
information communities
circulate, but the actual
infrastructures that allow them
to circulate. So I I became
pretty interesting In economic
anthropology at that moment, and
was reading quite broadly in the
kind of ideas around the culture
of, of economic practice, and
then was attuned to thinking
about, you know what those
infrastructure like how
infrastructure played a role.
Fortunately, I went to
University of Southern
California's Annenberg School
for my PhD. And fortunately, I
happen to be co located just
about an hour away from Bill
Mauer, who's a economic
anthropologist at UC Irvine, who
had been studying payments and
was really kind of the, like, I
became really interested in
payments and payment systems and
the infrastructures of economic
practice, and then just an hour
away was the only other person
in the world who at that moment
was actually interested in it.
And we met and we were able to
just, you know, have these long,
intense sessions where we were
just geeking out about the
things we knew about the Visa,
MasterCard network, or the you
know, the intricacies of the way
various payment infrastructures
worked. And at the time, we sort
of talked about ourselves as
like a field of two, that is no
longer true. And that wasn't
even true at the time, but it
was, you know, the people we
knew. So, and then the other
thing I really had to do,
though, and Mary's very sweet to
say, you know, you know, this
kind of official pedigree of
like, you know, who's
anthropologist who's not, I did
have to say, though, you know,
I'm not an anthropologist, my
training is not going to be
primarily anthropology, my
training is going to be
primarily in communication.
And then, and then the question
of, like, communication versus
Media Studies is another one.
But, but nevertheless, I, I had
to really almost use my training
and use the title of my PhD as
an oblique strategy to think
about, you know, what kind of
contribution I could make. So,
so what I came to think about
was this idea that, you know,
money is fundamentally
communicative, you know, a
transaction is a trans moving
action, a movement across a
movement from one account to
another. And whether that
happened, then, and then we have
to attend to the media, or the
kind of infrastructures or
technologies that that allow
that transaction to take place,
or enable that transaction take
place. And then what and then
ask questions like, what are the
politics of those
infrastructures? So while bill
and others are, are thinking
about it from like, you know, at
one point, Bill, and I were
having kind of these
conversations, and he, I
realized he brought to bear all
of this, I was always
intimidated, because he's a very
senior scholar, super genius.
And he knew all this stuff about
the anthropological record, and
I didn't, but then I realized,
oh, wait a minute, like he's not
thinking about it in this kind
of media studies and
communication way, and I
actually am, and all the ways
that I had kind of been taken,
taken for granted about my
training worked were a totally
new way to kind of think about
this. So, so yeah.
Aswin Punathembekar: But
especially when you say that one
of your goals in this book is
to, you know, move beyond the
taken for granted, notice that
money is something that's
symbolic and expressive. And
it's really fantastic how you
take what you just said, the
transaction, and then you work
it out in each chapter. And just
for those of you who don't have
the book, yet, each chapter
works out a different dimension,
a different sort of a different
logic of transaction that say,
with one chapter offering a
really wonderful short history.
I mean, this is really a model
for how to write a short
history. Then you go through and
say, you know, questions of
identity, politics, memories,
publics, and then finally
futures. And what I like is the
real nice narrative thread, you
have this notion of transaction,
and you draw so fruitfully on
James Carey. And what you
actually managed to pull off,
which is brilliant, is to
achieve a sort of synthesis
between the ritual and the
transmission views of
communication, that we all sort
of cite endlessly, but never
quite bring those two things
together in our own analytic
frame, which you do really well.
So I guess that leads to the
next questions. And there are
places which I've bookmarked in
my copy, which I'm going to
return to every now and then you
talk a little bit about
infrastructure. But I wish, I
hope we can talk a little bit
about the citizenship part and
really get into. And there's one
bit on page 107, where you have
this really evocative line about
getting paid. That the task for
those who hope to design how we
get paid in the future is to
figure out how to maintain all
the things that cash and so on.
And I was wondering if we can
talk given our current context
and also 2008 2009. Have you
also had a chance to reflect on
not getting paid, and how that
also figures in these kinds of
transactional transactional
spaces that we all inhabit,
given the global financial
crisis and given what we're all
sort of building No,
Lana Swartz: yes. And I think
that that question really
points, a helps B plate really
specifically to what I hope is
one of the key interventions of
the book, which is we tend to
think about the politics of
money, the politics of getting
paid and not getting paid in
terms of quantity and
distribution. So who has money?
Who has not enough of it? Who
has too much of it? And these
are sort of economic questions.
But there are also kind of
communicative questions we can
ask about the technologies of
money that we only really see if
we become attuned to thinking
about money as media money as a
technology. So I argue in that
chapter about getting paid that
one of the, you know, that,
that, that not having access to
the money that you have, and not
being able to use the money that
you have, is as good as not
having any money at all. And so,
so, and I use the example of a
and I think, you know, this is a
case I had to write about,
because I kept coming back to it
again, and again. But so I'll
just kind of briefly tell that
story. A story of a woman who
named Ethan Alexander, who was a
cam girl, online sex worker, who
had a medical emergency, you
know, very common, a very
catastrophic reaction to a very
common medication, and found
herself unable to work
essentially. And, you know, she
doesn't, didn't have health
insurance, this is before the
Affordable Care Act, and found
herself kind of in pretty dire
straits in the kind of American
healthcare system. And so, what
her community did, which is what
communities have always done is
they kind of pass the hat to try
to raise money to defer the
costs of, of her of her crisis.
And it being, you know, the 20
teens, it was done through a
crowdfunding campaign. And it
the platform is one that is no
longer no longer exists, but was
specifically geared towards
health care expenses. And so
because she was, you know, minor
celebrity had a lot, you know,
had plenty of Twitter followers,
she was able to raise money
fairly quickly. And one of her
friends who his personal
community set off, tweeted, I
will offer a free pick set
meaning pornography to anyone
who donates $100 or more to
Eden's campaign. Eden's own
Twitter account, there's some
question about whether or not he
was the one who tweeted it,
because she was in the hospital,
it doesn't matter, retweeted
that. And then suddenly, even
got a ton of messages stating
that her cat, her she had
violated the terms of service of
the, of the platform, the and
all donations, this Oh, and her,
her campaign had been suspended,
and all donations had been
refunded. And then there was,
again, kind of a, you know, huge
backlash, she had enough Twitter
followers for it to be the kind
of cause of the day, and another
crowdfunding campaign stepped in
and said, Oh, you know, we'll be
happy to help you, we'll step
in, and we'll, and that one also
no longer exists, but they were
trying to kind of make their
name off of being the helpful
platform, the good platform and
this kind of moment. But that's
not you know, something, most
people have the x, you know, the
ability to do, we're not all
able to kind of wield an army of
Twitter followers to do customer
service on our behalf.
So, when the, you know, people
were sort of examining and
offering various hot takes
around what had happened, you
know, even supporters somewhat,
you know, rightly said, you
know, kind of blamed the, the
crowdfunding campaign as being
like a group of tech bros, who
felt like it was their right to
create, you know, make moral
evaluations of who should be
able to get money and who
shouldn't. And then the
crowdfunding campaign said, Oh,
we will try to say like that
what actually happened was, when
she retweeted the offer for
pornography, it became a
transaction for pornography,
rather than a transaction for
crowdfunding. So it became this
kind of financial moment. and we
are required by our underlying
payments processor to not accept
an allow donation or
transactions for pornography,
that's, you know, part of a
thing. We're like a taboo list.
And then, and then the payments
processor. We pay said, Oh,
actually, we're not the ones
prohibiting it. It's our Visa
MasterCard network underneath us
prohibiting it. So is this kind
of passing the buck of who made
the rules that that ultimately
prohibited sex work from being
transactable on this site? And,
and so what I did and what I
think was really important and
my kind of training allowed me
to be able to do this was to
say, Okay, what really happened
here? Why are the rules the such
as that they are. And what I
learned is that basically in a
kind of old system of payments
acquiring merch individually or
merchants are able to acquire
payments. Well, I'll say
acquirers meaning like the banks
that serve merchants are able to
kind of acquire payments on
behalf of merchants according to
a particular set of risk logics
and risk appetites. And if you
are considered a high risk
merchant, meaning high risk for
chargeback meaning high risk
that the customer that you have
is going to say I want my money
back, then you will get charged
more for your payments. So there
seems to be belief, I have not
seen any actual evidence, this
is actually true that the
selling of pornography of any
kind produces a higher rate of
chargebacks. And the reason for
this might be that people say
like, oh, it wasn't me that
bought that subscription, it was
my kid or, or you know, Sorry,
boss or spouse, I didn't make
this transaction etc. Or it
could be that historically,
pornography, especially online
pornography is pretty scammy.
And you might like sign up for
you might think you're doing a
one time payment, but it winds
up becoming this recurring
payment. But for whatever
reason, it is received wisdom in
the payments industry, that if
you want to receive payments,
for pornography, you have to pay
more. But in the platform
economy, everything sort of
becomes one size fits all and
rather than there being this
kind of bespoke risk model on an
individual merchant basis that
you know, creates a market for
risk in the payments acquiring
system, it becomes a what
becomes like a way of pricing
variable kinds of transactions,
becomes a one size fits all
prohibition as inscribed in
terms of service, there is no
real way for for any kind of
platform to write a bespoke kind
of or even variable governance
system, it seems. So they just
say all the things that used to
be a little bit more expensive
or a little bit strange or a
little bit outside the norm for
the way we do payments are just
gonna be completely prohibited.
So it's this importing wholesale
without really considering it,
of one risk model into this a
new kind of risk model that
created this misalignment that
created what was also what could
have been a quite catastrophic
situation for this person for
Eden, and indeed, is a
catastrophic situation for
countless people who suddenly
and without real with without
any real ability to predict it,
suddenly lose access to their
payments.
So, for me, I really have been
interested in how like, people
are not just didn't denied
money, like just don't have you
know, enough money, but rather
are denied access to the money
that they have. And and what are
the reasons, like actual reasons
that that happens for I mean,
another example is like in the
United States under using EBT,
which is our kind of welfare
cards, you, you can only use
your EBT payment card to buy
certain kinds of merchandise. So
if you walk into a store, you
can't buy a hot chicken be even
though we're just re chickens
are a loss leader for
supermarkets, and are really
great for, you know, some
working person who may have a
family they want to feed, you
know, such as most people who
receive welfare.
They,
they often you know, so so you
can't buy a hot chicken. But you
can buy a hot chicken that has
been chilled and placed in a
chilled refrigerator system.
Because that is no longer hot
food that becomes cold food and
therefore, you're able to buy it
using your EBT card. So what
interests me and kind of
thinking about the code, like
social justice questions or
political questions of payments
is not just or money is not just
how you have money or if you
have money, but how the money
you have works and how the way
it works. Re inscribes or
produces new kinds of
injustices, new kinds of
inequalities and, and thinking
about those inequalities as
questions of access and
questions of kind of
informational and communicative
you know, sticking points.
Aswin Punathembekar: Yeah, you
have this really evocative line
at one point in that chapter
where you talk about the
profound implications of what
you call losing the citizenship
of a transactional community and
that line is really gets to the
racialized and gendered sort of
dimensions of what you've just
laid out so, so wonderfully
well. And I was wondering if
given that you started this
project in LA, and you were
going back and forth between
Irvine and other spaces, and La
itself was a space, this notion
of losing the citizenship of a
community, of transaction of
moving across spaces and moving
over time. I was wondering if
there's a link between migrants,
migration, immune systems, that
were part of your thinking at
the time where others, perhaps
in your community have economic
anthropology, meats, Media
Studies, or others working on
it? Or how have you seen that
emerge? And asked that, in part
because there's this really
amazing piece that you have
about memory, and he said, money
is memory. And those three words
money, memory migration really
come together in very powerful
ways for me, and I wanted to ask
you to reflect a little bit on
those three key words.
Lana Swartz: Yeah, so when I
think about money as memory, I
come at it from a few different
perspectives. So I think about
you know, it's, it's interesting
that the idea that money is
memory is something that occurs
across many different fields of
scholarship, who are not at all
in communication with each
other. So for example,
economists, like kind of game
theoretic economists talk about
money as memory, because in in a
kind of game theory, context and
kind of an economic experiment,
you can, you can either have a
tally system, so like a system
of, of keeping accounts that
everyone can see a kind of
memory system, or you could have
a money system, meaning tokens
that people exchange, and in a
cot in a economic experiment.
Either way, the whether you have
a memory system or a money
system, it kind of produces the
same outcomes in gameplay. So in
that sense, like money is a
literal like, exit memory, which
is a term that actually Nancy
Boehm I got from Nancy Boehm, a
science fiction book, Nancy
Boehm wrote, but it's this kind
of collective memory or external
memory system, that we use to
remember in a, you know,
economic sense. Our
transactions, you know, I have,
we have transacted, I have paid,
you know, you have the money,
and I don't, and we both
remember that that transaction
has occurred. But then
anthropologists who are not at
all in communication with, you
know, this particular stream of
game theory, we'll also write
that money as memory and they
mean that yes, it is this way of
keeping track of our entire
obligations, but they mean that
in much more of a, a kind of a
sense of kind of socio, that
kind of socio cultural
dimensions of that. And, and so,
you know, Viviana Zelizer and
economic sociologists talk about
these kind of like spheres of
exchange and networks, well,
they all there's like some
people, there's like, some
people say network, some people
say spheres, some people say
circuits, etc. But the way that
money kind of traces the
tessellations of our inter
obligations to each other. And
then thinking about the
question, I mean, I would love
to kind of, you know, hear your
perspective, and just because
you're have thought so many
fascinating things about this,
but I'd love to, you know, kind
of hear how it intersected for
you on the question of
migration. But I will say that
many economic anthropologists
had have studied money systems
as they relate to remittances
and as they relate to kind of
like, development. And, and very
few, very little attention had
been paid to the kinds of
meaning and politics of payment
systems in the United States as
though the and this I think, is
an error that you know, so we
tend to repeat again, and again,
as scholars, but as though
economic transactions in
primitive societies are more
meaningful, and economic
transactions in the West are,
you know, so much more economic
and so much more uncoupled from,
you know, social aspects. And so
I wanted to kind of resocialize
Western money and northern money
and, and, and demonstrate the
contours of the kind of
inequalities inscribed there in
So, so yeah, um,
yeah, I want to hear what you
have to
Aswin Punathembekar: I can chime
in as well. But even before we
get to that, I'm also mindful of
the time and yeah, we can take
questions. So keeping in mind
that we wanted this to be
oriented to at CMS grad students
and other early career scholars
and PhD students listening in
one of the other bits of your
book that I thought was worth
reflecting on a little bit was
the sheer range of
methodological tools you had to
pull together. The were crossing
across these different
theoretical domains. So in one
sense, as a good Media Studies
scholar, you really pulled
together different kinds of
artifacts and read them as
texts, you do this really close
thematic analysis of
advertisements, like credit card
sort of surfaces like these,
that I'm holding up to the
screen. But you also sort of
trace process. So it's almost
like I read it as a process
geography kind of book, where
you're going through the
lifecycle of a certain kind of
transaction that gets going. And
then you're going to follow it
through to lifestyle. And along
the way, you're going to do deep
dives into different moments to
have moments of interaction and
which institutions which actors
are then come into play, which
networks get activated, and so
on. So could you say a little
bit about that dimension of your
project? What were some of the
challenges? Did you have to
learn new methods? Or did you
have to retool some methods to
bring, as Dalton said in the
chat window, to bring this
communication perspective to a
very new object that median
income studies has not tended to
take into account?
Lana Swartz: Yeah, so I mean, in
some ways, I think this circles
back to the question of learning
about an object as a community
formed around it. So you know, I
came to thinking about money at
a time when a lot of people were
thinking about money, and kind
of a lot of people were
reimagining the infrastructures
of money. I mean, the term
FinTech basically, came of age
during the writing of my book.
Certainly, cryptocurrency and
all of that emerged during the
writing of my dissertation, and
then book and so I was
effectively thought of myself as
an ethnography offer. But I was
an ethnography of communities
who were rediscovering or
rather, we're discovering there,
the genealogy and the history of
the thing that they were
interested in. So like me, lots
and lots of, of entrepreneurs,
artists, activists, said, you
know, we need to read, you know,
I'm fascinated by money. I'm not
sure why, but I'm fascinated by
it. And I, and I'm, and I'm
desperate to rethink it. And so
let me now Now I have to
suddenly learn everything about
the way the Visa MasterCard
network works, or like the way
the Automated Clearing House
works. And so like, like them, I
thought, okay, like, how do
people? How do people in this
industry learn about these,
like, really boring systems? And
the answer to that was, they go
to industry boot camps, like,
where you learn, you spend one
week doing a super deep dive in
how, how these kind of legacy
systems work, and everybody else
around me was either employed by
a legacy system, like a big bank
of reeds, MasterCard, etc. And
they were I was literally doing
the employee training, that
people who work in this industry
do, or they were learning about
them, because they wanted to,
like disrupt and revolutionize
them. And then there and I was
sort of there learning about the
thing, but also doing an
ethnography of all the people
around me. And then, like many
of the people around me, there
was the opportunity to kind of
discover histories I joke that I
am, unfortunately, or for better
for worse, like probably one of
the world's experts on the
Diners Club card, which was the
first third party universal
third party payment card that
emerged in the 1950s and 60s,
and to kind of, and, and so so
Diners Club still exists. It's
more popular in some countries
than others. But it has gone
through a number of different
mergers and acquisitions, and is
now I think, most recently owned
by discover. And it was
purchased by discover for its
international network. But
during many of these kind of
transitions, its company archive
was lost. So another thing that
I've learned about is that many
large companies have their own
archives have their own library
and have their own archivist.
And those can be tremendous,
tremendous sources of
information for thinking about
the kind of history of
technology and history of
business. But Diners Club have
been lost. At one point, it had
been outsourced to a company
that now I think, also no longer
exists called the history
company know the history
factory, that was meant to be a
steward of various corporate
archives, but somebody stopped
paying the Diners Club bill at
some point. And this kind of
went off and, and smoke so I
wound up doing kind of, and this
is something I've learned a lot
about from Kevin Driscoll, who's
my partner, but also a media
historian, which is the kind of
eBay archives that kind of eBay
histories where you set up your
eBay alerts and you buy
everything that you know for a
couple bucks that relates to
kind of the early ephemera of
the thing you're interested in.
So through that, I discovered
for example, that early Diners
Club cards, had these kind of
books. And this is actually I
have a very short piece, which
I'd be happy to send anybody,
which is in my edited collection
from MIT Press called pave,
about the Diners Club, about the
Diners Club and the way that the
card itself was one innovation,
but really, in order to find how
to use a Diners Club, find a
way, the way to the only way to
use a dyers go card was to know
where it was accepted. And the
only way to know where it was
accepted was to have these kind
of guidebooks that told you
where and you could look up like
any town anywhere in America,
and know that your card will be
accepted there. And so I, so I
kind of begin to realize from
kind of looking at the books,
which I only learned about
because I found them on eBay,
that they were kind of the key
innovation. And they were the
kind of key Wayfinding tool for
the transactional community of,
of the Diners Club card. And so
in the short piece that I wrote
for MIT, the MIT book, I kind of
compared it to the Green Book.
So the, you know, the Negro
motorist screen book, which
helped, you know, African
American travelers navigate the
segregated United States and
find safe harbor while on the
road. And I then discovered just
by kind of pivoting into kind of
more traditional historical
approaches, you know, just like
newspaper archival searches,
that in the African American
press of the mid century, of
which there are many African
American newspapers, there is a
lot of talk about how, you know,
on the road, there was no way to
pay for anything, except through
something like a Diners Club
card, because, you know, there
were no major bank networks,
there were a you know, you
couldn't go to bank America on
any corner and pull money out of
an ATM, they hadn't been
invented yet, it was pretty hard
to get a merchant to accept an
out of town check, because they
would be pretty hard to kind of
track down. You know, it was
easy to do check fraud. And so
the Diners Club card basically
allowed people to travel and be
accepted to kind of book places,
you know, pay for hotels, pay
for rental cars, etc. And in
African American press, there
was a lot of talk about how
African Americans were not
really able to take advantage of
the innovation of the Diners
Club card, because they faced a
new kind of de facto
discrimination when they showed
up, they, you know, to pay for
their motel room, and the clerk
said, Oh, Diners Club card,
well, if you could just get
cash, we'd be happy to give you
a room. And so these kind of new
layers of privatization on top
of the kind of transactional
technology of money created new
opportunities for new and
innovative kinds of
discrimination and racism. So
and the only way I would have
known about that, or the only
way I was able to figure that
out was by kind of circulating
around and around through the
kind of pivoting between eBay
history to more traditional
forms of history. And the only
way I really began to think
about the Diners Club was from
pulling from the kind of
ethnographic ethnography of
industry contexts. So you have
to kind of constantly be
pivoting between different kinds
of approaches. And just sort of,
I mean, I think back to a piece
actually read and CMS which was
the Fis cher, Mike, Michael
Fischer and George Marcus's,
like multi sided ethnography,
which just encouraged you to
think about everything
ethnographically whether it's
historical work, or other kinds
of like, you know, looking
deeply at documents, and and
follow threads, however they
need to be followed, I also
begin to think of myself as
doing like an ethnography of
PDFs, because so many of the
standards of these systems,
whether they're like the Visa,
MasterCard guidebook, or like
any number of cryptocurrency
white papers are inscribed as
PDFs. So like engaging with
that. That network of of kind of
non human actors that guide
these spaces was also like a
really important part of my
work.
Aswin Punathembekar: I'm glad
you referred to Marcus and
Fischer. Yeah, word of
historical anthropology. And the
idea that I think I read the
same article to may have been in
miracles class, about multi
sightedness not being just
endlessly sort of multiplying
the number of sites, but to
think of each site in a very,
very careful way and how that
each site is implicated in a
network of other forces and
factors. Some humans are non
human. And I guess I'll close by
saying that one of the real
pleasures of your book is you
you manage to intersect with so
many different emergent
subfields platform studies,
critical infrastructure studies,
media, industry studies,
critical race studies, and so
on. And you managed to Pull
those threads into chapters as
and when you need to get into
certain crucial conversations
that are ongoing, but at the
same time managed to stay
focused on this narrative thread
about transaction. And that is
no easy task. So I guess I'll
end with this question about
transport writing your first
book, it's a monumental thing to
do. So congratulations, again,
it's such a great achievement,
and to do it so beautifully is
really no mean task. And so can
you tell us for everybody
listening in, especially grad
students, early career scholars
make struggling their way
through that first book? What
were some of the challenges?
What were some of the pleasures?
And if you could even give us
like a glimpse into those
moments of sheer joy, where you
realize, that's it? All the
bloody years? Now I get it after
eight long years? Yeah. Tell us
a little bit about that process?
Lana Swartz: Well, I'm not sure
if I have felt
Arctic release just yet that I
got it done. I mean, it's, I got
it done. Right, I got it done.
But I don't know that I always
feel that I got it done. Right.
But I mean, I, I also just have
to say, you know, when you
mentioned kind of the litany of,
of sub emergent subfields that I
draw from, and a big part of
that is the network of people
who I have had the tremendous,
you know, good fortune and
privilege of, you know, being
exposed to some of whom are here
today. And, you know, certainly
kind of Kendall Square between
my CMS time and my Microsoft
Research time, has been
incredibly, you know, important
to the kind of formation of my
intellectual life. And as it
emerged in this book, and I
guess, that both of that
happened kind of before and
after the dissertation, um, but
I would say, I, you know, in the
exciting structure of the book,
for me are one of the, the
exciting ways of untangling a
puzzle was to kind of think
about following through the
actual mechanisms of
transaction. So getting paid,
kind of processing those
payments, paying, and then the
kind of data that emerges and
test leads out from there, and
then actually being able to look
and deeply attend, and I could
go on for quite some links in
the book and could go on, and,
you know, chattering about it
for even longer about the actual
material processes that underlie
the way the, the way
transactions actually function
in the kind of like baseline,
Visa, MasterCard payment system.
And breaking the book down into
a chapter that, that chapters
that examine each of those
processes, and really giving
myself permission to not spare,
or, you know, to be willing to
kind of give the technical
detail as much of a close read,
as I, as I felt they needed was
really freeing. I often am
frustrated, frankly, by, by
scholarship that talks about
algorithms or talks about, you
know, technologies as though
they were all one thing or as
though like, you know,
algorithms, what are they we
don't know, but they're bad,
which that's nobody here. But
But I think that that tends to
be a problem. And so like,
really, really digging into the
technologies themselves. And
then exploiting them out was
something though, yeah, I'm glad
there's Sorry, I'm monitoring
the thing on the side, um, you
know, that that was a gift
allowing myself the time and the
space to really unpack the
technologies and, and treat
them, you know, as though they
were cultural texts and cultural
artifacts, which they are, was
something that I, I was very,
I'm grateful to be able to have
had. And I'm grateful to readers
who are willing to spend the
time to actually read some of
the boring stuff that I find so
fascinating.
Aswin Punathembekar: No, not
boring at all. If anything, I
think it's the richness of that
detail. that then allows the
reader to then step back and
really come to terms with the
fact that it's out of these
details, that the social life of
transaction really emerges. And
what's what's held together
throughout, is what you just
said, which is we said what
becomes newly material, that's
another phrase from your book
that really stayed with me, and
you and you sort of do the, the
attention to the material
dimensions of different, more
different processes, like you
said, of paying, getting paid,
paying somebody been mowing
somebody, something And so on,
while not allowing those
material dimensions to somehow
over determine the social, so
the both of those things remain
autonomous in your framework.
And you managed to do manage to
hang on to both of them, without
necessarily sort of, you know,
making facile directionality
arguments about this leading to
the other, you know, it's in
that sense, it is, I think, an
exemplar of doing the kind of
conjunctural work that a Stuart
Hall might say, like, have put
everything into context, keep
the two things together in one
frame, and see where the story
leads you. Right, which allows
you to, I think, be really open
to new insight, rather than
going in and saying, This is
what Ben was doing. So yeah, I
couldn't recommend this book
highly. And, honestly, this is
sort of an exemplar of media and
transition. All of you on this,
go get a copy a lot. I will,
when when, when a book tour
happens when a white book tour
happens, we come to wherever you
are inside the book for you. But
I
Lana Swartz: did have someone on
Twitter offer to buy a signed
copy of the book via Bitcoin.
And then yeah, so I'm open to
that. But then in the DMS, they
were like, Oh, actually, can I
not give you a Bitcoin? Because
like, I don't know if you know,
this, that bitcoins pricing is
like, highly variable. And so
why would I pay for a book? I'm
like, the talk. Um, so yeah, I
was hoping for the book.
Aswin Punathembekar: Yeah, I'm
sure there are lots and lots of
questions, waiting in the chat
queue that Andrew can, perhaps
moderate or Scot, depending on
who wants to take that go. But
please, everybody join me in
congratulating Lana again on
this, on this terrific
achievement? And yeah, thank
you.
Lana Swartz: Yeah, thank you all
for, um, you know, allowing us
to do this kind of experimental
chat. I hoped it was a little
bit, you know, I know, we all
have zoom fatigue. So I hope
something a little bit more
interactive was more
interesting. And thank you so
much for Aswan for asking such
insightful and, and very kind
questions.
Aswin Punathembekar: Let's Yeah,
let's
Scot Osterweil: Yeah, let's see
what else is there? No, in
keeping with the spirit of this,
let's start with see whether
there are questions from the
students first before before I
go to the chat list, or the QA
that Thomas you have here? Is
that you raise your hand? Yes,
go ahead.
Tomás Guarna: Um, hi, I'm Tomas.
I'm a first year CMS grad
student. And so I'm interested
in Well, obviously, you look at
me and transition, which is what
we weren't supposed to. And I'm
interested in how to how do you
study the ship isn't like
novelty and continued
continuity? I feel that
sometimes we're like saying
everything is new. And it seems
as we're saying, like,
everything is the same always.
Mm hmm.
Lana Swartz: Yeah, so the a
phrase that I had to excise from
the book, because I use it too
many times was, but there is a
longer history here. And, and so
I do think that kind of looking
at the new and then situating,
the new, we're looking at this
moment of transition, which you
know, is new at any given
moment, and then doing this kind
of genealogical work to kind of
figure out what are the
necessary histories that need to
be known. And then I have found
it really useful. So I think
about money, one of the
analytics, that that kind of
money. Money, as a object of
study has gotten me is to think
about the way money creates kind
of shared futures. So we only
use a form of money, and accept
a form of money, because we
believe it'll be worth something
tomorrow, or the next day or the
next day. And we are and that
is, you know, a kind of
performance of the, of the
acceptance of the authority of
whatever, bodies authorize that
value of that money. So, you
know, I might feel a lot of
anxiety about the death of
American democracy, but I'm
still willing to accept, you
know, and use US dollars as
payments, because I don't feel
that much anxiety about it. But
nevertheless, I get questions
from interviewers, I've gotten
questions from multiple
different journalists this week
about people, you know, moving
all their money into bitcoin
ahead of the US election. So it
so that kind of analytic that
kind of way that money creates a
shared future or a sense of a
shared future among those who
use it became a way for me to
kind of think about future. So
how do the people who use a
shared money form understand a
shared past? What do they not
know about that shared past?
What do I need to know about the
shared past to understand this
like moment of change? And then
how does that give an object
project into a future and what
what kinds of like what array of
possible futures are made
available by the object of study
and the community that surrounds
it? And so your whatever you're
talking is going to be very
different. But I think whatever
your topic is, will yield its
own ways of structuring shared
paths and shared futures and
understanding these kind of like
shared presence. And as long as
you are able to endeavor to
think analytically about all of
that, you'll kind of I think
that's like a pretty useful way
to kind of deal with that
question.
Tomás Guarna: Thank you.
Scot Osterweil: Diego, I see
your hand up.
Diego Cerna Aragon: Oh, yeah.
Ah, thank you, Anna and asked me
before the conversation, I have
a question as somebody who is
also interested in the kind of
like intersection of media and
economics. And so how does
somebody from your size engage
with economists? Because
economics is this really well,
fence field, or at least it
seems to be this really well,
fence field? That is really
worth but the practitioners and
scholars in the field? And and
at least in my experience, it
seems to be that basically kind
of like media size US, okay,
there are these like, it's farms
that are only looking at the
corporate dimensions of the
economic practices, right. But
there is more to it. Right, I
want to get from, from the front
of your conversation is that
there is all this like, material
semiotic a mention of the
practices of economic right, and
that this dimension has, like
actual consequences in our
economy. Right. But how do we
show them that this that this
dimension has is important?
Right? That's what I keep
pondering about.
Lana Swartz: Yeah, I mean, I
guess my answer to that is to
use the language of economics is
to say, what is the utility of
convincing them? And there may
indeed, be utility. But the, but
then ultimately, they kind of
what is the outcome that you
want to have? Like? To what
extent, you know, I've
definitely had the feeling that
I really wanted to be more
respected by the economists that
I've interacted with. But I
ultimately don't get anything of
that much use to me from being
respected by economists. And,
and then if the question is,
okay, economists have tremendous
power, and they've been able to
marshal their kind of like,
weird, non empirical way of
doing theory into a kind of
like, political power. You know,
maybe that's useful, but then do
you have to go through them to
get what you need, or to do what
you need to do? So I think it's
like, you know, figure out what
you want to get out of it. And
then, you know, go on from
there. I will say, for me, and
this is unique to my case,
economists, a very small group
of economists are some of the
only people who are have
historically been interested in
payment systems, because they're
interested in two sided markets.
And so there are, like, people
who want to geek out about
payment systems, who are in the
field of economics, and they're
excited to talk to me, because
I'm one of the only people who
shares that interest. So and who
is like reading their papers
from 20 years ago? So I do think
that I do think that that, you
know, you find common ground
that you want to stand on with
those disciplines. And then you
figure out why you want to
interact with them beyond that.
I mean, I don't know, I'm, I
might be too early in my career
to give you more of a of an
answer than that. But I think
kind of like living in and
performing your confidence. I,
some of you will know what I'm
talking about here. But I, I
know, I have met economists in
my life, literally. Who are who
I have now turned this, like,
there's a particular economist
that I know and I turn this
mantra where I say what, what
his name is not as one but let's
pretend same as as one where
anytime I do anything in life, I
say, what would as when do what
would as when expect, what kind
of like privilege would this
economist expect to be like,
dropped at their feet? And then
that gives me the power to say,
you know, like, what I try I try
to use that too. empower myself
to behave as an economist would.
So you know, it doesn't always
work, but most of the time
doesn't work. But it's um, it's
important to kind of destabilize
the kind of accepted regimes of
academic authority.
Scot Osterweil: Kelly
Kelly Wagman: Hi, thank you for
the talk. I have kind of an
analogous question, which is,
what has been your interaction
with the like tech enthusiasts,
Silicon Valley dudes who want to
remake payments? And have? Have
you had any discussions about
your work? Or do you hope to
like change minds? And if so,
how? And?
Lana Swartz: Yeah, that's an
interesting question. So I
started, as I've mentioned, like
in this space, when the space
was kind of gearing up, and
early on, you know, there
weren't that many people
interested in. In this kind of,
I mean, there were, but it was a
smaller community. And so early
on, I was invited to give lots
and lots of talks to like
FinTech groups and Bitcoin
groups and that sort of thing.
Some of which sat at the
intersection of academia and
activism. And so which didn't.
And the, that was like a
important like ethnographic
opportunity for me to kind of
try to figure out how to be a
critical expert in this space
when he when in fact, I was
quite early on in my work. And
it sort of speaks to the
question of like, empowerment
and authority were like, they
didn't know what they were
talking about, either. So I
could kind of like Marshal my
own ability to end and also
really think about what could be
interesting for these groups,
like, what could I bring to
bear. And then an interesting
thing happened, which is, I
wasn't saying anything. That was
like monetizable, or that was
like, fed the hype machine. And
if anything, I was kind of a
hype killjoy. Early on, and they
were like, Oh, no, we don't
invite her again. And then a
kind of interesting thing
happened, where like, we all
ride these like waves of hype
cycles. And suddenly, it's like,
cool to be critical about these
things again, and so now,
fortunately, corresponding with
my book, but also unfortunately,
corresponding with a global
pandemic, I'm now getting lots
of new invitations to kind of be
the kind of critical voice which
they kind of now decide that
they, they need to have, I'm
just cool. And then the other
piece is that, like, asking the
question, like sincerely asking
a question, like, what do
industries? And what are, you
know, activists and you know,
people who want to try to make
change from one direction or
another? What do they actually
need to know, has proven to be a
really useful analytic for me.
Like, I found myself studying
industries, but the industry
isn't very interested in
learning about themselves. And
so I had to kind of think for
whom is learning about this
industry? Interesting. Is it
interesting to people? Is it
interesting to users of payment
systems, whether which we all
are? And then I had to think,
like, maybe not really, so like,
what is interesting? And to
whom? And then how do I kind of
use that to kind of put it all
together to create a book that
is kind of interesting to
someone. And so now, it's an
interesting thing, where I
think, you know, the industries
are interested in hearing
critique, but they're also
interested in hearing about
history. And then I, I do hope
that the kind of like users at
large are interested in, in
learning about how these kind of
systems actually work and
thinking about ways that people
kind of sit at the intersection
of user and perhaps like, change
maker can kind of think past the
kind of easy stories about like,
all good, all bad, and kind of
dig into some of the the kind of
details, I think, one of the
most important things to me to
kind of communicate to at least
the kind of startup community
and the kind of crypto community
has been to really attend to and
really think about how much
human labor and of course, you
know, you can hear traces of all
the interlocutors that are some
of whom are in this room that
I've had over the years. But,
you know, that, that, that did
repeat new kinds of
disintermediation of financial
transactions via things like
blockchain don't suddenly make
things happen by magic, but
rather, are when they work if
they work, which they usually
don't. They're the outcome of a
lot of like human effort and,
and to try to get the industry
to think about how discovering
hidden systems and how important
they are through the process of
remaking them doesn't mean
doesn't have to mean re
submerging them as though all of
the kind of infrastructural care
work that went into producing
them was instead kind of this
like the outcome of a
you know, technological magic.
That makes sense. So, so yeah, I
think like always keeping in
mind who, who would care and
like and like what your
different audiences are and what
you can tell them and and then
think about. And then also think
about, like, what the key
takeaways would be for the kind
of most empowered stakeholders?
You know, might be for you.
But yeah, having to be like,
what do I really, and I bringing
to anybody has been like a
really, really useful way for me
to figure out what I could
actually bring to anyone
Scot Osterweil: affects Um, so
I, unless I see another question
from a student, for the sake of,
since this is recorded, it's
sort of my job to sort of read
questions out loud, just so that
they get heard. The chat, by the
way, is full of your fans, and
all sorts of I'm not surprised
all sorts of flirt sort of
enthusiastic, supportive
comments, I actually sort of do
see one genuine question there
from Mary gray. Which is, do you
consider platforms like venue as
re socializing of money?
Lana Swartz: Yeah, so if we
think about Venmo, so Venmo, is
talked about, as you know, for
almost probably most of you
know, what Venmo is, oftentimes,
when I talk to international
audiences or you know, older,
like adult audiences, you're
adults, but you know what I
mean, I have to kind of explain
what Venmo is, because it's
something that's like, very
widely used among people under
30 in the United States, but not
at all used beyond that. And
it's basically just makes
payments into a social feed. So
you can you attach annotations
to your payment. And then you
can also surveil the payments
that other folks in your network
are making or in public are
making. So it is often talked
about overtly as a payments, I
mean, as a social media system
as and this attempt to, you
know, make money into something
that is social, sort of make
money social. And in fact, I
remember having a conversation
with a very well known payments
consultant at a big payments
industry trade show, and she was
like, you know, people have been
trying to make p2p kind of peer
to person to person transactions
happen for 20 years. And who
knew, all it would take would be
to be able to add emojis to it.
And I was like, Yeah, but also
You're right, like, Who knew
that money sort of like wanted
to be social, and, and that by
like, like, allowing us to kind
of surface the sociality of
money would kind of make it
something that would, you know,
people actually wanted to do and
use. At the same time, of
course, you know, when we say
money is social, it can kind of
only be social in the kind of
Silicon Valley meaning of the
term. And so when you when you
hear people in those industries,
faces talk about money as
social, what they really mean,
if they're like saying, oh,
we're doing social payments,
what we really mean is that
they're doing payments, whose
main, you know, Mountain
monetizable, monetize ability
comes through social media data.
So there's this like,
interesting intersection where,
you know, Silicon Valley,
rediscovers that money is, in
fact, social, only through the
process of enclosing that
sociality as something that can
be commoditized. For in one way
or another. I am though, I will
say and I just want to give a
quick plug to this, I am really
excited about Tim Long's new
book about I forget what it's
called, but it's basically about
how social data might be the
next like, big bubble, because
like, there's only so many ways
we can do predictive analytics
to drive more advertising. And
that, you know, might be kind of
like the big lie that undergirds
like all the systems that we
like and enjoy. So I be very
curious to see if we ultimately
do have some kind of crash
around that. And then, you know,
what happens? How do we think
about the sociality of money and
sociality of other, you know,
other platforms that we've
invested so much of our lives
in? If we they suddenly are
discovered to be less profitable
than we imagined?
Aswin Punathembekar: Yeah. Yeah.
And the I mean, to
me rigorous Mary's question also
sort of prompts the observation
that the default publicness at
the heart of platforms, like
when Moe and many others and
default publicness has been
written about quite a bit,
right. Is that something that
becomes the focus for you when
it comes to thinking about both
the challenges but also the real
risks of that mode of
publicness?
Lana Swartz: Yes, yeah.
Aswin Punathembekar: What's at
stake when communities that
aren't in the windmill
ecosystem, don't get or don't
become part of the imaginary of
Silicon Valley Tech Bros. Right.
And so here I'm thinking back to
our brief back and forth about
migration meets payment systems.
And I'm wondering if this I
don't know this much, but I'm
wondering if there's real
opportunity there to do some
deep historical work where
boundaries zones, and I'm
looking at the big balls work
here, in sense that when a group
of migrants land on the shores
of some space, and when there is
simply no commensurability,
between different forms of money
that are circulating in that
community, both of which happen
to be marginalized within the
American racial system, what
happens then? So I'm wondering
if that sort of deep historical
work is also crucial if we are
to recognize the very real
limits of the imaginations of
Silicon Valley, other kind of
tech spaces like Accra, in
Ghana, Bangalore, India, you
know, what sort of state driven
initiative, so yeah, not to put
you on the spot? Because,
Lana Swartz: yeah, well, so in
terms of, I'll just give a quick
shout out to an art piece called
public by default by an artist
named Hang Do Thi Duc, which is
referenced in my book where she
looks at kind of the humans of
Venmo. Where and she uses she
downloads, like all Venmo
transactions from 2017, using
their public API, and uses it
not to, you know, find
terrorists or stop fraud or
whatever, but instead, to kind
of paint these portraits of the
people and the kind of human
lives behind the Venmo
transactions. And I think that
her and her piece is meant to be
cautionary, so it's meant to
say, you know, look at all the
things I can learn about you
through Venmo. And hear all
these compelling reasons and so
easy to just change your
settings, so just do it. But at
the same time, the piece like
really straddles this line where
she shows how kind of like
poignant and like real, these
like moments of transaction are.
And it perfectly for me
oscillates between the, um, you
know, the very real sociality of
payment and money, but also the
kinds of dangers of of living in
this, like newly public way of
kind of publicly doing
transactions. And the other
piece I want to mention about
that, though, is that for me, in
some ways, the advertising
pieces is the main way we think
about monetizing the internet.
But actually the primary uses of
payments data, at least four
payment apps winds up being
operational. So like predictive
analytics that like the kind of
Eden Alexander story, I told,
prevent against alleged fraud,
alleged violations of Terms of
Service and that kind of thing.
So they wind up being these kind
of like, like they are used, the
ultimately transaction data is
used to power and animate the
transaction systems themselves.
And so then the problem then
becomes these moments when they
stop working, they they break
down, you can't access your
money, you can't pay with your
money. And, and so, and, and
those those, you know, ruptures
happen because of the data
produced by the systems
themselves. So I think in some
ways, like, it's not so much
that the data is, or the
transactions are viewable or
survivable. But then like, how
they're used, and who makes
sense of them. I mean, if you
think about Venmo, Venmo is the
most public of, you know,
transaction systems. It's the
only one that I know of that has
like a really solid public API,
whereas others, like, you know,
Facebook and Google tend to be
more like data hoarders. So like
kind of what happens, like what
kinds of what kinds of degrees
of publicity and privacy are,
are useful if and for what ends.
But to your question about
transaction transactionality.
that this isn't exact, I do
think I absolutely think more
work needs to be done along the
historical lines you describe,
but the thing It reminds me of
is his two anecdotes that one up
in the book, which is the way
that people continue to use
money systems that are based in
one place, even as they transit
to the to another place. So my
students always tell me about
how when you know what I teach
classical money and technology
where we lay all this out. And
again, and again, they say, it's
so interesting, I've heard this
exact same story again, and
again, that when I was in study
abroad, or when I went abroad
for the summer, my friends and I
in my friend group had one
designated person who handled
the money meaning handled the
money of whatever locale they
were in trafficked in euros or
pesos or whatever. Whereas we
all settled up in the background
using Venmo. So we were all
living in the kind of this micro
transactional community and we
had one kind of envoy into the,
you know, transactional world
around us. And so this kind of
experience of being this like
fumbling.
maladapted user of a foreign
money was like Something they
didn't really get to experience
because they were primarily
living within the kind of safe
harbor of something they
understood, which was Venmo. And
all those Venmo transactions
were settling up on cloud
computers that were assigned to
United States, and therefore,
they may have left the United
States, but their money never
did. And similarly, there are,
you know, with WeChat, if we
think about, you know, China,
you know, there is a, a Chinese
restaurant, across the street
from the University of Virginia,
where we chat is accepted. And
WeChat pay is accepted. And and
Chinese students will look at
WeChat, to see the kind of
moments to see the specials of
the day, and transact entirely
with WeChat in this with this
restaurant and amongst
themselves. And similarly,
WeChat can be used at all
Caesars owned casinos in Vegas.
So when I was at these money
trade shows, in Vegas, I saw
large groups of Chinese tourists
transacting entirely in WeChat,
except for with gambling,
because you're not allowed to
use it to buy gambling chips.
That's the one prohibition fully
remaining within the kind of
communicative world and
transactional world of China
even as they traveled beyond. So
I'm really interested in how
payment and this kind of goes
back to the Diners Club thing
thinking about like payment as a
Wayfinding tool payment as a
tool of geography, remakes,
geographies, in ways that don't
simply map to territoriality,
like what does it mean to be
somewhere? And, and what does it
mean to be somewhere even as
most of your communications,
including your financial
communications, are happening
somewhere else, so to speak?
Aswin Punathembekar: Absolutely,
there's a history to be told as
a story to be told about, like
you said, with the person who
handles money for all the study
abroad, students mediating
personas, perhaps Money, Money
handlers, and I'm thinking about
the grocery stores that I relied
on, and the grocery store owner
who could mediate for me,
basically remittances for, you
know, through the 90s, which
have now disappeared from a
certain kind of cultural
geography and the geography of
urban sort of, you know, cities,
with WhatsApp with WeChat, and
so on. So this is interesting.
So that's what I meant when I
said, How do we recover that
those kinds of imaginaries of
relationships across space being
sustained by networks of
payments, that tech bros in
Silicon Valley in either have
the interest nor the inclination
to grasp that form of sociality?
Right. So that's what I was
doing to Vivek and wondering if
Bengali Harlem has stories about
payments and money, as a crucial
form of sociality, for the kinds
of people who landed up in
Harlem at the turn of the
century, but not so.
Lana Swartz: Yeah. Well, one
thing I will say about Harlem, I
just wanna say one thing about
Harlem at the turn of the
century, rather, Harlem in the
well, Manhattan in the
postbellum period, is that in
the United States, the state
issued currency was not fully
consolidated until well after
the Civil War. So if you were
entering Manhattan, whether as
an immigrant from the
hinterlands in the United States
or from anywhere, you suddenly
had to navigate all very
communist monetary ecosystem,
and David hanken, who's a
historian has a really great
book called city reading, that's
about all the different forms of
reading the largely illiterate
population of major cities had
to do and meaning he means New
York in the 18th and 19th
century, and being able to say,
Okay, this banknote is real,
this bank note is fake, this
bank note is real, but it's from
a bank that went out of
business, this bank note is
actually issued from a private
bank, that would be good in
Philadelphia, but probably isn't
good in, in New York, and having
to kind of end or be like, this
one's probably not good. But I
guarantee someone else will take
it was a crucial way of being
street smart. And I think, and
this is kind of like a big
takeaway that we didn't really
talk about from the book is
that, you know, people often ask
me what the future of money is,
and I don't think state issued
currencies are going anywhere. I
don't think cash necessarily is
going anywhere. But what I do
think where we'll be seeing is a
new period of monetary
plurality, where we will be
having to negotiate many, many
different forms of money both in
the kind of rails, the systems
that power them, but also like
these mediated forms that they
take, but also the kind of
tokens of, Oh, it's my knees,
not look at the chat. Okay. I'm
saying so. And so how do we live
in a world of plurality? How do
we negotiate that plurality? How
do we deal with deprecated money
forms?
Aswin Punathembekar: I
underlined sentences we say that
a plurality could mean your
transactional life is very gated
omnivorous, constantly shifting
between different monies,
different communities. Yeah,
Lana Swartz: yes. And I think
learning to live with pote
plurality will be the kind of
key political question of our
kind of monetary lives in the
next in the coming decades.
Scot Osterweil: Yeah. We have
two very thoughtful questions in
the q&a. Do you guys have time
to stay past 630? Or do you
need?
Lana Swartz: Let's do can we,
um, so I should probably go for
family reasons. But maybe if you
can just read the two questions.
And we know we can say like,
five more minutes, but if
anybody needs to go, please
don't I will, you know, bye.
Thank you so much for coming.
Yeah.
Scot Osterweil: Thank you, I
have to disappear at 630. But
the questions, one is from Radu,
it's when studying money, I tend
to go to the heavy emergence of
microtransactions and video
games. How can we think of this
the same way we regard dollars
in society as a way of getting
us a product or good? Are they a
commodity in themselves? So
that's one like, Okay, second
question. Thanks for a great
talk. Sorry, for the long
question. Exploring money as
media, I was wondering about
your take on the similarities of
oppressive economic sanctions,
impacting citizens of certain
countries, denying them the use
of global financial system, and
the new global social media
excluding and D platforming
certain people and views, this
idea of legitimize exclusion of
the international scale,
targeting millions of citizens
denying them access to the
increasingly centralized forms
of transaction, whether it's
money or knowledge, and of
course, for access to knowledge,
one needs to engage in financial
transactions as well.
Lana Swartz: I think I mean,
that's a those are both super
interesting, really astute
questions. And I think they
really speak to like the heart
of what I'm trying to argue in
the book, which is like,
especially this idea of
legitimize exclusion. And you
know, deep platforming, via
access to money, and money, you
know, financial systems, kind of
speaks to this idea of like,
not, the not having access to
money, or to be able to pay and
be paid is as good as like not
having money at all. And so
like, really, really developing
a political imagination around
the rails of money, rather than
just around the
the
economic distribution of money
is really important. And to kind
of speak to the Daniels
question, you know, that's where
we come in, like, we don't need
to be economists, we need to
study the things that we study
with the tools that we have,
because we have really important
things to say, and economists
would never think about the way
that it you know, it's not
simply the sanctions themselves
via, you know, economic
relationships, it's the way that
sanctions are enacted via, you
know, PayPal, Visa, MasterCard,
and like banks, that that do the
work of transactional
communication via what we call
media systems via what we call
technology systems. So like, we
look for that, like, look for
how our are, we have the ability
to ask questions that are being
obfuscated or simply treated as
like, like, treated as, as the,
as something lesser than the big
picture, but reality, like
that's kind of where the
inaction of these policies
actually live, and what that
looks like. So yes, absolutely,
I think, and I think that that's
really complex, and we need to,
like spend a lot more time
thinking more about it. And
similarly, I mean, I think we
could say, you know, that
microtransactions, and video
games are actually quite
similar, you know, like, what
are the, you know, what are the
ways that that new monies are
designed as products and the
kind of like, both the rails of
them that transmit them around
the information systems that
allow them to exist? And then
like, what are the kind of
political economies of money
themselves? So if we can use
something like
microtransactions, to enquire
after the Political Economy of a
new money form, we can develop
an apparatus that allows us to
apply that to a, you know, to
living with global money
plurality, as it relates to, you
know, economic sanctions in the
way that they're deployed via
particular infrastructures. So,
yeah, I think oddly enough,
those are two questions that
kind of hung together, I guess.
Scot Osterweil: Yeah. And you
were brilliant in sort of
wrapping them up that that, that
well, so yeah,
Lana Swartz: but I mean, I will.
The final thing I'll say about
writing this book is that it's
kind of like a first book on a
topic and that you have, as
economics, economists would say,
like a first mover advantage,
but there's so much more work to
be done. And kind of like
opening it up for more
conversation is like a huge part
of what I hope the work of the
book is.
Lots of unanswered questions.
Scot Osterweil: Thanks so much.
Thank you.
Unknown: Yes. Thank you all.
Thank you, Aswan. Thank you so
much. This is
Scot Osterweil: so many both
wonderful to have you both back.
Lana Swartz: Yeah, it was really
fun.
Aswin Punathembekar: sometime
soon.
Lana Swartz: Yeah, and I hope
this format was some, you know,
was interesting for you guys.
So, all right Take care
everybody.
Bye
Aswin Punathembekar: Bye
Lana Swartz: Bye